welcome to this video playing hora bets
from the US let's play the English for a
change
I can't we probably go to a mirach C
point yep we get the main line Roxy at
least I can play some some quick moves
here
yeah Jarvis has to be confused about the
move order there are various ways to to
play this move otherwise
okay so it's going for six Bishop g5
it's an interesting setup that's not
sure about this precise position feels
like maybe a bit premature how does seem
I want to see cavity six now or let's
say after the trade not sure you want
the position with both takes on e5 and D
takes very often you can play such a
structure Bishop e5 d5 when you get a
piece to d4 but this looks very foul of
the knight on c5 is not quickly coming
to deform okay so I can take him play
queen III want to want to play this
quickly I mean this is a position type
that I've had on the board quite often
so no use in setting up a time loss
against the sky
yeah blacks counterplay is some
connected with f5 and this is still a
valid option here okay I don't think
black is some is in terrible shape you
can certainly play this I'm not easily
playing a3 before my bishop is not very
good
maybe I can get the bishop to see to its
really am not that place on each oh look
before I have 92mm so nothing terrible
happening them or bishop see to then 92
yeah not much to do here it's very very
equal if I'd if I trade this now he will
get any five so I shouldn't shouldn't do
that I could come nighty - but she's got
Queen a1 that's it's not good
I don't mind him trading the Sun is
perfectly okay for me
hmm it's not easy at all to play him
maybe as Ken can get in a three reform
then trade or something hmm yeah
very tough
Oh No
before Quincy forecheck ah no
oh that's terrible now that's really
charming what does what does stupid
mistake a three there are great just
great
maybe I can take and play before maybe
this is stir
maybe this still holds if it if it holds
it's just luck pure luck
now it takes c3 I take here and get to
get the night maybe this is still
sufficient maybe until K can make he can
probably invade on the dark squares I
should should start with E fire
we are definitely okay but if he moves
the night away I will take a four
probably night b3 okay so we get get
this and here probably I must go if I've
to avoid King f6 yeah here takes takes
but it should be okay I can I also have
an eye on the e4 pawn one of the sudden
check the worse is definitely over here
key to e5 but I can't go to e3 that's
okay
whether that's hi morning it's no way to
play this for when I think check check
check
maybe I can do something with the pony
Zach yeah he's a for to to attend to h3
maybe or just he and let it go
check check
draw offered no I'm not sure about this
and now it should know it black you know
I can take here and okay you know yes
one second black for fits on time yeah
three thought the endgame would still be
better for me when I declined the drawer
but I'd also do it it is it is but I'm
and shouldn't go there why is this
winning I don't understand
we should be aid then is getting it to
d5 to d5 yeah yeah yeah this is much
better then going into b7 but okay I
didn't ever didn't have much time yeah
winning this is of course very strange
I completely overlooked a for here Wow
yeah this is not a very comfortable
endgame I thought initially it's
probably equal but it's it's just easier
for black to play here this should
probably end in a draw but I was a bit
surprised why it didn't take on g3 I
mean like certainly wasn't trying to win
now I mean as I would this would be very
strange as SES they four-week just check
check check
gerrant yeah I just take it and it gets
critical for black yeah tough to analyze
but it didn't get anything out of this
opening I need to check this really okay
thanks for watching